[Music]
jumping back to a fireman just for a
second he had a little bit of an ego yes
what do you think ego is powerful or
dangerous in science I think both both
both I think you have to have both
arrogance and humility you have to have
the arrogance to say I can do this
nature is difficult nature is very very
hard I'm smart enough I can do it I can
win the battle with nature on the other
hand I think you also have to have the
humility to know that you're very likely
to be wrong on any given occasion
everything you're thinking could
suddenly change young people can come
along and say things you won't
understand and you'll be lost and
flabbergasted so I think it's a
combination of both you better recognize
that you're very limited and you better
be able to say to yourself I'm not so
limited that I can't win this battle
with nature it takes a special kind of
person who can manage both of those I
would say and I would say there's echoes
of that in your own work a little bit of
ego a little bit of outside-of-the-box
humble thinking I hope so so it was
their time where you complete you felt
you looked at yourself and asked am i
completely wrong about this oh yeah but
the whole thing about specific things
the whole thing what do you weigh which
cold thing me and me and my ability to
do this thing oh those kinds of doubts
first of all did you have those kinds of
doubts no I had different kind of doubts
I came from a very working-class
background and I was uncomfortable in
academia for Oh for a long time but they
weren't doubts about my ability of my
they were just the discomfort and being
in an environment that my family hadn't
participated in I know nothing about as
a young person I didn't learn that there
was such a thing called physics and
thought I was almost twenty years old so
I did have certain kind of doubts but
not about my ability I don't think I was
too worried about whether I would
succeed or not I never I never felt this
insecurity am I ever gonna get a job
that veteran never occurred to me that I
wouldn't
you